this program is brought to you by Emory
University my name is Kenneth hallett
and I'm director of sustainability
initiatives for emory university and one
of the things that people don't often
think about related to smoking are the
environmental impacts smoking is the
leading cause of deforestation and water
pollution tobacco production requires a
lot of wood and in brazil alone about 60
million trees every year consumed just
for tobacco production in terms of water
pollution tobacco requires a lot of
chemicals and fertilizer and that leads
to both groundwater and surface water
contamination and cigarette butts alone
are highly toxic and nan de
biodegradable and every year about 1.7
billion tons are contributed to our
oceans rivers and streams so if you want
to reduce your environmental impact and
you want to adopt a sustainable practice
then to stop smoking is a wonderful
thing that you can do the preceding
program is copyrighted by Emory
University